I went to [music] Chattanooga,
Tennessee, which is where Desmond
eventually retired and passed away and
went into his his old woodshed and
handled [music] his tools and walked
around the lake that he would walk
around. I spent the day there just kind
of praying
and and and asking let's just guide me
through this. If you can hear me, tell I
tell me tell [music] me what to do. Tell
me how to move. Tell me how to speak.
Tell me how to behave and I'll do
whatever you say. Before I started work,
I went over to Christ Cathedral and I I
sat by his grave [music] and I prayed a
rosary with him. I sat down and I prayed
with him. The space just to his right is
[music] empty. So, I got to sit down or
lie at one point I even lied down
because I just thought it would be kind
of interesting [music]
to try to connect in some way. That's
probably more information than you need
or may even want to publish. But, that
said
you know, I it's the truth. And so, I
finished praying with him.
And I said, Lonnie
I want to honor you with this film. If
this is a good idea that I do this film,
have somebody give me a sign. Give me a
sign and God give me a sign. And the
minute the words left my mouth, behind
me there was a door open to the
cathedral and this giant chord
rang out for about 5 seconds.
And then On the organ? From the organ.
Wow. I hadn't heard it before. I heard
that and I was like
Okay.
Thanks for that.
>> [laughter]
>> So, I I always like to think of it as
like I've got him sitting there,
whip a little message at him, whip a
little moral at him, whip a little of
what my view of the world is because
that's what every good filmmaker does.
>> So, they know without a shadow of doubt,
you watch this stuff, you will be
changed.
>> Television, this is where I spent 10
years in Hollywood. I ended up in the
television industry. These world views
that are getting promoted out there in a
lot of this mass media, that's actually
what these guys actually think about. I
mean, they're they're promoting these
ideas. If it got out that there [music]
was an environmental message to this
film, it would cost us 50% of our box
office. I'm glad [music] that it has
gotten out that
you know, that was the original
intention. Like and queerness, like
incorporate as many things as possible.
That's actually what these guys actually
think about. I mean, they're they're
promoting these ideas. I've talked to
Hollywood producers when I lived in LA.
I happened to be the doctor taking care
of people at an urgent care in LA County
and met celebrities. They want to shape
the way you see the world.
>> know, you kind of hope that [music]
you're preparing the way, planting
little seeds in the minds of people.
It's just there and it's it's slowly
changing a perception. What you're
watching is going to be accepted in the
brain. And there's a very direct way
that this happens that we'll [music]
talk about in a second.
So, today we're going to get into a
topic, television. This is where I spent
10 years in Hollywood in Los Angeles. I
ended up in the television industry. So,
I'm glad to have you on Dr. Eric Walsh
for some expert opinions and facts on
this subject because we need to talk
about it. The entertainment industry has
had a voice in our modern world and is
like something that that that people are
getting information from. So,
I'm going to I'm going to hear what you
have to say about this. Well, thanks.
It's great to be on again. And let me
start by just saying when I was a kid,
it was television. It was just
television. We had four channels.
We were poor. My mother would not get
cable. But, NBC, ABC, CBS and PBS.
That's it. Our remote control was a pair
of pliers. And
you know, we had a a hanger as our cable
system and one of us sometimes would
have to hold on to. So, TV was very
limited and yet even then it was very
dangerous as we'll see.
And when I we speak of television today,
we're not just speaking about old
school, you know, box in front of you or
a flat screen now. We're talking about
iPads,
cell phones, anything that can stream,
Netflix, Amazon Prime, what else is out
there?
Apple TV, Hulu. Hulu. All these things
are the source now. And so, where
television before I had four channels,
my mother would not buy a color TV. So,
we had a black and white TV with four
channels.
We'd much rather go outside and play
most of the time because
>> [laughter]
>> TV was really not that good. Today, it's
very different. Yeah. Children are
captivated by screen time, which affects
sleep, which you won't talk much about
today, but it affects sleep. And what we
will talk about is the way this thing
changes behavior
and your spiritual walk. Absolutely.
>> That is the big thing that that we're
going to look at today. So, I know you
have history actually working in this
industry.
I have a history watching a lot of TV.
>> [laughter]
>> That's my history. I'm the expert. I
think for me working in television, you
know, I I moved to Los Angeles in 1999.
There was a big big strikes in all the
unions and stuff. So, if you were
non-union, you you could pretty much
walk on and get a job and reality
television was booming. And most of the
stuff that I was working on was like the
bottom feeders. I mean, we're talking
the the lowest of the lowest junk. And
and I think what it did for me is it
really made me lose like that like you
know, you kind of take a magnifying
glass and you put it on the crazy parts
of humanity and just kind of become
desensitized by it. And like how the
news works, right? You see all these
awful things that are happening and you
somehow go, my life's not as bad as that
thing over there. And that that to me
made me just kind of like eh
until it got worse and worse and worse
and then I finally was just like, what
am I working on? What am I doing? And
God got a hold of my heart and now I'm
working ministry.
Amen. Let's look at TV. New York Times
had this article, "You Are What You
Watch, The Social Effects of TV."
I won't go through this, but you know,
the etymology of the word entertainment
is that it goes inside you. You guys I
think you guys seen you guys talk about
this before. Entertain, it grasps you.
Meant, it kind of controls you. So, it's
something that enters you to control
you, grasp hold of you.
And this this Anne Bogart says this,
"Entertainment might provide the access
to deeper parts of the human experience
beyond gratification and towards
insight."
So, they understand that entertainment
can change it. I've talked to Hollywood
producers when I lived in LA. And Holly
people who wanted to get into Holly,
people were in Hollywood. I met I
happened to be the doctor taking care of
people at an urgent care in LA County
and met celebrities. You know, I won't
say who. And this to this is part of why
they do what they do. They want to shape
the way you see the world. Yep. Yeah. I
I remember uh
I keep forgetting the guy's name, but he
says whip a little more at them. Oh,
Kevin Smith.
>> Kevin Smith. So, he's one of the
directors. Yeah. Yeah, he says this is
what every good filmmaker does. We whip
whip a little more at them, moral. We
whip a little of what my view of the
world is at them cuz that's what every
good filmmaker does. Yeah. And he's a
director. Yeah. And it's true. Like like
you know, we showed that clip of the guy
from X-Men, Bryan Singer. And and you
know, he was commenting that hey, we put
a coming out scene in the X-Men. Why? He
himself is also doing that and he's and
even Robert Redford was like, hey, he's
going to put in the video what he is
dealing with in life as well.
So, uh
when did you first know you were a
mutant?
Would you cut that out?
You have to understand, we thought Bobby
was going to a school for the gifted.
Bobby is the gifted.
>> We know that. We just didn't realize he
was
>> love you, Bobby.
It's just
this mutant problem is a little
>> What mutant problem?
complicated.
>> of times that's that's that's what's
happening. These these world views that
are getting promoted out there in a lot
of this mass media,
that's actually what these guys actually
think about. I mean, they're they're
promoting these ideas. So, yeah, it was
it was part of our show that we redid
recently about Snoop Dogg. He was
calling out like speaking against these
LGBTQ characters in the kids movie,
Lightyear. And so, in that show you also
showed a clip of Desperate Housewives.
Do you know about Desperate Housewives,
that show? I know the show, but I don't
>> Yeah, yeah. I I used to watch it. I
didn't grow up Christian and so, it was
like a thing for our family night to
watch Desperate Housewives, but
garbage.
You know, and my mom who is now a
Christian as well would agree with that
now. But, at the time we we that was a
thing that we did as a family and you
showed that I think it was like the
screenplay writer or somebody who was
involved with the show said, "Oh yeah,
so we put a
homosexual couple
on Wisteria Lane, which is the street in
Desperate Housewives where all these
ladies live. We put them there on
purpose and they don't even do anything.
They're just in the background. They're
just part of story. They just live
there. Nothing is in your face." But, he
literally used the verbage, "We're
planting little seeds just like in the
Bible we're supposed to plant seeds." He
said, "We plant seeds so that
over time you become used to this idea
of homosexuality and it might change
your perception of it and you start
accepting it."
>> [music]
>> One of the things I'm proudest about
is the addition of the neighbors, the
gay neighbors on Wisteria Lane because
they're there, they're a part of the
neighborhood. No one seems to notice it.
And I think that just having gay
neighbors be a part of the street
and I don't really talk about their
sexuality much. To me, that became its
own political statement, which is
you can have gay neighbors and they can
be perfectly fine and fit in with with
you know, the rest of the folks.
And it doesn't change anything. And you
know, you kind of hope that you're
preparing the way, planting little seeds
in the minds of people who sometime over
the next few years are going to have gay
neighbors buy
a house on their street.
And for me, that that's that's the most
effective political message is that it
it's not particularly aggressive. It's
just there and it's it's slowly changing
our perception.
>> Wow. You are a seed planter. Everyone is
a seed planter. And and you know, I
think the hard thing for some people to
wrap their minds around when they when
they hear the word entertainment is it's
just fake. It's not we know there's no
such thing as superheroes. How can this
possibly affect me, right? But we know
like, hey, how do you learn about God?
You got a Bible. What's that Bible full
of? Oh, interesting stories. And and the
more stories that you hear about and the
more that you understand from the story
perspective about God, the more you
build up a world view in your mind. It's
exactly what the devil's doing. He's
telling his versions of the stories, but
he's using his people and they're just
getting the the the message all messed
up. Let's look at that. So, here's an
article Kylie Fuller uh published in
Illumination. It's not just a movie how
television shapes our brains.
>> Mhm. Television puts us into a hypnotic
state. What does that mean for us? Well,
so from the article, movies and
television put us into a hypnotic state.
Within seconds of turning on the
television or any screen, our brain
waves lower to an alpha state, which is
where we are most impressionable. The
information we see or hear on the
television, whether it's the news or or
a or a fiction film, works on our
subconscious mind. What does that mean?
What we believe, how we perceive the
world and ourselves, our values and
aspirations,
all of this can be reconfigured
by what we watch on television. Remember
this is a secular article. Now
scientists know that these changes occur
on a neurological level. Watching
television can change how much we use a
certain we use certain brain areas and
how these brain regions develop. For
example, watching more television can
increase the size of the visual cortex
and sensory motor cortices. However, it
can also negatively impact the activity
of the frontal polar regions here, the
frontal lobe again, of the brain, which
is associated with with intelligence.
Television affects you.
Electroencephalogram studies show that
in fact it brings you down to the alpha
waves. The The last one said a hypnotic
state. This one says a daydreaming state
in the study.
And reduced use of
critical thinking skills.
Television is designed to dumb us down.
That's literally what television is
designed to do. To dumb us down and make
us not able to um
analyze what's coming in. So, they're
not just planting something in the
background. They understand it when
you're in this alpha state,
what you're watching is going to be
accepted in the brain. And there's a
very direct way that this happens that
we'll talk about in a second.
Now now you know this is true when you
see certain groups um that are
advocating you have to have x amount of
percentage of this type of people into
this video, you know I mean the LGBT has
fought long and hard to have
representation in there. So, if you take
a listen to that and you go, why would
you fight so long and hard? Why would
you go to the great length to try and
bend these big corporate companies out
in Los Angeles because you know that if
that's in that movie, that will
ultimately affect people.
That's why you're doing it. Because if
it didn't matter, you wouldn't do it.
>> Yeah. So, they know without a shadow of
doubt you watch this stuff, you will be
changed. Mhm. That's right. And so,
let's look at that. So, here's another
article too much TV may be bad for your
long-term brain health. People who watch
large amounts of television in midlife
experience greater cognitive declines in
their senior years. Mhm. It's not just
children, which is often what we focus
on. Watching television alters
children's brain structure and lowers
their IQ.
>> Wow. Right? There's another one. This is
Johns Hopkins again. These aren't
Christians. Johns Hopkins magazine new
study suggests that too much television
really can rot your brain.
>> Mhm. How does all of this work? Well,
there think there are neurons in your
brain called mirror neurons. I don't
know if you guys have ever talked about
this.
>> Yep. And so, you can see that there
there's a clinical relevance to it. When
you watch something, it's as if you
participated in it. They got this from
studies on monkeys. They had the monkeys
hold a banana and it activated a certain
part of brain. When the handler of the
monkey held the banana, that same part
was activated. They began to look into
it and they realized when you watch
television or you see someone do Forget
television. Even in an a theater theater
like old school Shakespeare in the park,
you when you watch it, there's a part of
you that participates.
Um and this is why we've always said by
beholding we become changed. This this
really shows the danger of it that if
your brain cannot differentiate between
seeing and doing, you just saw somebody
get shot, your brain registered it as I
just saw so or I just, you know,
experienced that or saw that or or maybe
did that. And so, yeah, that's that's
flat out dangerous. Well, let's take it
a step further. If you just watch
someone do it, a part of your brain
participates. What happens when you're
the one actively pulling the trigger on
the video game to do the shooting? So,
you're watching it and you're actually
participating physically. There's a guy
that um he wrote a book and in fact a
manual that teaches um cops and military
people how to aim a gun at somebody and
be able to pull the trigger because most
people we we have this thing called
preservation of life that's inside of
us, right? It's very difficult to put a
gun in a healthy person's hand and say
point it at that person pull the
trigger. Most people can't do that. And
and it would take a lot of effort for
you to actually like like shoot and kill
somebody. But he said that the way that
they train is they'll make a shape of a
target or whatever. And the more that
you shoot at a shape of the target, not
just a bull's-eye, but an actual
human-looking target, it breaks down
that defense. So, ultimately they're
giving these safety guards to to um cops
and to military people so they can react
without having to like think about it.
Like you're just going to pull the gun
out and and react to the situation. And
he made the correlation between we we
have kids training this way in video
games all the time and we have put no
safety nets on this thing. We you
literally have a nation full of kids
that are doing the same psychological
breaking down, but we've put no stopping
on them.
>> Well well, let's let's look at it from a
different angle. When you have a bunch
of romantic sexual scenes in movies, and
then
>> We're getting there. Yep. I mean like
what what if you're like a married
couple and you're watching somebody else
do that? And it's a it's a romantic
movie. I mean like
Yeah, it's awkward. Isn't but but for a
lot of people are so desensitized it's
no longer awkward. Yeah. Which is a
problem. So, what is the next step? Like
watching pornography together?
>> Right. That's what a lot of people
actually do.
Yes. But but think about it, right? Like
um you're sitting there and sure in most
cases, that's probably
getting less now, but in most cases,
you don't see the actual
act, you know? But you see the body, you
see the body, you understand exactly
what's going on, and you're sitting
there watching it.
You would never in your right mind, if
you're especially if you're a Christian,
hopefully, not think to yourself, I'm
going to sit on the couch and I'm just
going to have two people do this in
front of me. No, you wouldn't, right?
But why why you do it on the screen and
then it's mirror neurons. Your brain
can't differentiate the difference.
>> taking pleasure in something that you
are And that's why there's so much
sexual perversion as we're going to see.
So, the first thing I want to jump um
by beholding we become changed. Here's
what that takes you.
What is happening now is that we have a
new thing that didn't exist when I was a
kid. There was nothing to binge watch
when I was a kid.
>> Right. If I missed an episode of the
Cosby Show, I had to wait till summer
when it was in reruns, read a TV guide,
which I never had, figure out when that
one was going to come on and watch it.
So, there if I'm like if my mother took
us grocery shopping on night when we
wanted to watch something, we just
missed it.
Game over. You probably would never
going to see it again in your own mind.
Maybe years later in reruns you'd catch
that episode. Yeah. Not anymore. No.
Satan has given us on-demand access to
things that can completely corrupt us.
And like the rat in the cage with the
lever to the cocaine, he has given us
these ways to just overindulge. So,
let's look at the science a bit behind
binge watching cuz we don't talk about
this enough. Cultural anthropologist
Grant McCracken, who coordinated with
Netflix on the above survey, sees a
correlation between the rise in binge
watching binge viewing habits and our
desire to escape a never a never-ending
sea of bite-size social media
posts and YouTube videos. He explains,
"Television viewers are no longer zoning
out as a way to forget about their day.
They are tuning in on their own
schedules to a different world. Getting
immersed in multiple episodes or even
multiple seasons of a show over a few
weeks
is a new kind of escapism that is
especially welcomed today." The response
that we talked about in the previous
episode, the fact that social media has
shortened everyone's attention span.
But there's one big exception.
Binge watching.
Right? You can't [snorts] sit in front
of a a a preacher and listen to a sermon
for an hour. You got to getting fidgety,
you want to leave, you start thinking
about lunch. You can't sit in front of a
teacher professor for an hour, but you
can binge watch for hours. If someone
said 40 years ago, "We're going to make
a movie 12 hours long," which is what a
season is like, you know, 8 to 12 hours
long,
>> They'd be like, "No one's watching it."
>> Nobody's watching it. But we do it today
through binge watching. True. It locks
us in and really takes over and we begin
to binge watch. And what I like about
what this what this what this what this
scientist is saying is, "We're not even
doing it to tune out. We're looking for
somewhere to to be. It's escapism
because we're social media has made us
so disconnected, it has set all of us up
to want to connect even further into the
false world of Hollywood."
>> Right. To the detriment of probably your
real life relationships or like you're
not spending time with your I mean if
you're if you're a family person and and
you have kids, I mean, I don't
understand how people have time to watch
TV, period. Like, I don't have any spare
time when I go home, you know? It's
like, I'm trying to like hang out with
my kids, trying to cook with my wife,
trying to I mean, it's just like no time
to sit down. And and so, you're you're
sacrificing something. And if you're
doing it late at night, you're
sacrificing your sleep, which is also
not very good for you like mechanically
speaking. Um so, yeah, it's this is a
bad state. So, a a Bible verse I want to
throw in here is Isaiah 8 18 through 20
says, "Behold, I and the children whom
the Lord hath given me are for signs and
for wonders in Israel, the Lord of hosts
which dwells in Mount Zion. And when
they shall say unto you" and this to me
speaks to the media today on all forms.
"When they shall say unto you, seek unto
them that have familiar spirits and unto
wizards that peep and that mutter,
should not a people seek unto their God
for the living to the dead?" Should we
really seek to escape into the foreign
world of television rather than going to
God when life is difficult and we need
an escape? So, he then gives you the
qualifier in verse 20. Isaiah says, "To
the law and to the testimony, if they
speak not according to this word, why
would they not speak according to that
word? It is because there is no light in
them."
>> Mhm. That's an interesting point that
you're bringing up here because, you
know, escapism is very real. That's I
mean, people people all like to forget
the hardships of life and their jobs and
their whatever, you know, relationships
and they want to go and and watch a
relationship movie and feel that passion
again and stuff like this. I mean,
that's if everyone was honest, that's
why probably people are drawn to this
thing in the first place. Um going back
to your rat with pushing the cocaine
button, right? They say that when they
remove the cocaine away from that rat,
if given enough time, then the rat will
go and do what what you know, do do
normal things again. But, if you cause a
hardship on the rat, it will actually go
right back to where the cocaine was and
like as if it's looking for it or
waiting for it. And if it's there, it'll
go right back to the action.
And it's like, if you're using this to
escape during hard times and we know,
biblically speaking, some hard times are
coming, Yeah. where you going to go when
those times get hard? You need to go to
God. You know, I I had a personal
experience with this because I I
realized a few years ago that I got
addicted to YouTube, full-on addicted.
Did a video about this on YouTube
explaining this. And
and, you know, I was living a very
lukewarm Christian life.
I was basically just watching YouTube
whenever I could.
And I realized for me it had started as
a result of past trauma that I started
doing this escapism into YouTube, right?
And so and so,
growing up, my my my in my room, I
always had a TV and I always had a
computer like as a child, which I think
is
Don't do that with your kids, but I had
one. And so, that was my go-to. When I
had a bad day, I would turn on the TV,
watch MTV and Nickelodeon and all that
stuff. I didn't watch it for years and
then all of a sudden when this came up,
I started watching it and I got full-on
addicted because of the emotional
connection to it. And so, for me,
eventually
I realized this has become a false god
in my life because I go here and I don't
go to God because this gives me the
quick dopamine fix and I and with God
it's like an actual deep relationship
where where, you know, God's not going
to just give me like an injection like,
"Okay, you're good." God's like, "Let me
help you. Let me move you forward." But,
that was I didn't want that. I wanted
the dopamine. And so, the way I actually
was able to overcome that besides lots
of prayer and and honestly, I married a
really good husband who was involved
with God that I wanted more of God
because I saw him do those things. There
were multiple facets, multiple things I
talk about a little bit in the video
where I talked about this, but
the thing that that the that I believe
God gave me was actually there's a
little device that I could recommend to
everybody. It's 60 bucks. It's called
Brick. That one's specifically for
iPhone, but they have other ones for
Android as well, where you know how you
tap to pay with your phone? So, you can
use that same technology, you tap the
brick and it locks all of the apps you
want to lock. And you if the brick is
physically removed from your phone, you
cannot [snorts] unlock your apps. So,
you can go somewhere else and if that
thing is
wherever, you can't access it. And that
I think for some people you need to cut
it off completely off. And we live in a
society where you cannot sometimes not
have a smartphone. Unfortunately, that's
the society we live in. Then these are
really helpful tools and I think it
would help a lot of people. But,
honestly,
God has to be at the center because I
started realizing for myself this is a
salvational issue. If I don't cut this
false god out of my life, I'm going to
lose my soul over it. And I don't want
to lose my soul or lose salvation over
watching YouTube and and because Christ
was there and he wants me to overcome.
The whole time he wanted me to. He never
ever left my side every time I asked him
for help. He never did. And I believe I
believe the problem was for me that I
didn't want to let go. But, but I know
that if we ask for help and genuinely
say, "Lord, help me." And the Lord says,
"Okay, but you have to listen."
When you listen, he will help you. Amen.
Amen.
So,
>> [clears throat]
>> what happens to your brain when you do
this binge watching? As we just talked
about that, what actually happens to us?
Well, our brains actually do begin to
change, right? So, there's a whole
thing. This is Script News. This is the
neuroscience of addictive television,
the surprising impacts of binge watching
TV has on our hormones and sleep. So,
the first thing I would mention is
something you mentioned earlier. It
damages your sleep quality when you
watch this much TV, when you stay up
late watching this stuff. And it is
addictive, so and it's very pleasurable
to do it. But, what happens is one, the
blue light's hitting your eyes. You're
not making melatonin. The quality of
sleep that you're supposed to get to,
you never get to. Here's what I want
people to know. It is when you sleep,
God designed us so that when we sleep
and we dream, when we have the deep REM
sleep, that's when trauma is actually
naturally dealt with.
It actually you dream the dreams are a
way God designed us so that dreams are a
way that blunts the effects of trauma.
So, when you dream, you process what's
happened
and you blunt the release of
noradrenaline in your brain or
epinephrine, same thing, in your brain
so that in real life
it doesn't bother you as much when
you're awake.
Hence, why when these combat veterans
come back from war, they have PTSD, when
does it most affect them? At sleep.
Yeah. So, I want to say to people out
there that say, you know, you know, I've
been through some stuff, I've had hard
times, I've been traumatized, what is
your sleep quality? Sleep is one of the
first best things you can do and having
good sleep hygiene around exercising
early in the day, not eating late at
night,
having your room the way it's supposed
to be, but
you know, most germane to what we're
talking about today, do not allow social
media, binge watching, any of those
things to creep into your sleep hours.
That's the first thing, but it affects
even hormones. So, we know it we talked
about dopamine in the frontal cortex.
You can see literally that's where it
affects. So, the frontal lobe is about
is the is like the front third of the
human brain. It literally is what
differentiates us from the animals. And
in many ways when God said he made man
in his own image, it has something to do
with either the structure and or
function of the frontal lobe.
>> Right. The ability to reason, critically
think, worship, all of these things are
housed in the frontal lobe. Behind your
forehead bone is an area called the
prefrontal cortex. It is where we really
are most human. So, the human brain is
33% frontal lobe.
Um you know, the next smartest animals
are porpoises and chimpanzees. They're
only 13% frontal lobe. The frontal lobe
is also where it is the most holy place.
If our body is the sanctuary, the temple
of the living God, then this is the most
holy place cuz this is where sin is
dealt with. Isaiah 1:18 says, "Come, let
us reason together," says the Lord.
"Though your sins be as scarlet, they
shall be white as snow." Where does
reasoning happen in your whole body?
>> In the frontal lobe. Only in the frontal
lobe. So, salvation is a frontal lobe
process and operation. Hence, the whole
great controversy, let me make it real
plain. The entire great controversy for
you as an individual is a war for your
frontal lobe. It's a war for your mind.
>> So, this is why they're promoting
marijuana. This is why alcohol is
everywhere, ubiquitous. Everyone wants
you to go drink with them. This is why
music is the way it is, why social media
is the way it is, why television and,
you know, and the these streaming
services are the way they are. All of it
is an attack on the frontal lobe to
disqualify your frontal lobe from
receiving the seal of God.
>> Right.
Right.
>> This being the dopamine
like, you know, pathway and also the
frontal lobe being
hugely interested in in in pushing that
dopamine button
is [snorts] God designed us with this
pleasure chemical that's inside of our
brain, right? So, that we would be
addicted to things that let it's like,
"Hey, that felt good. Do that again."
Like, "Wow, I was nice to that person
and that really felt good. Do that
again." Wow, I I I I did something
selfless for this other person. Do that
again. And it's like the devil's just
hijacked that. And so, now when you need
to feel good, he's making you feel good
doing things that are awful or stories
that are that are not godly at all or
whatever. And he's using that chemical
button so that you get attracted to that
instead of helping other people. What is
it's tolerance. So, in in some of my
talks I talk about what we call this
dopaminergic syndrome. And what's
happened is everything stimulates
dopamine and you develop tolerance to
it. So, God designed it so that there is
a like a tiered system to the release of
dopamine. So, let me So, dopamine can
actually stimulate addiction, decrease
sense of pleasure. So if you're
overstimulated with too much dopamine,
it's more difficult to sense pleasure.
So what happens? Well, if you are deep
into
certain things, the pleasure you should
get from just coming home and seeing
your wife isn't going to be there.
When I come home and I see my wife,
there's a dopamine release. There's a
happiness I naturally have that you're
supposed to have. Now God designed it so
food, water,
sex, sex is the highest natural release
of dopamine. All these things supposed
to happen. Music does it. So all these
things are set up, but God tiered it. So
food only does a little bit. Cocaine on
the other hand, I don't have that slide
on this deck, but cocaine would release
a flood of dopamine. So when you look at
this, it
it's not just pleasure that dopamine
does. This is important. It's
motivation. Once you find something that
gives you dopamine, you get pleasure.
You lose motivation. This is what
marijuana does. This is why marijuana
causes amotivational syndrome. It takes
away the desire. Anyone grew up with
people who smoked a lot of pot, you know
that there's a lot of them
a large percentage of them eventually
just don't have the drive to do better
in life. Right? It just you just lose
that because you've messed up the
dopaminergic system in the brain through
marijuana. Here's the thing. Paul says,
"I press toward the mark of the high
calling of God in Christ Jesus." That is
a dopaminergic function that you're so
motivated
to want that relationship with Jesus
Christ. So if he messes up your dopamine
system and its sensitivities, you then
have no drive for God either. And you've
seen that with kids. And going back to
our point for today, television does
that. You know, you get the dopamine
crash.
And you see what ultimately happens you
destroy the system. So again, let me
we're not talking about marijuana, but
I'm going to throw this in there cuz
somebody may need to hear it. Marijuana
works here. Every other drug works up
here, causes this mass release of
dopamine into the into the synapse
between the presynaptic nerve, which is
this top one, and the postsynaptic nerve
on the bottom. So you take cocaine, lots
of these things release, you get a flood
of dopamine, every receptor is
triggered, then retriggered, then
retriggered. You get high, you want
dopamine you want cocaine again. Crack
is even worse because of how much faster
it works. Heroin works super fast.
Television doesn't work this fast, but
it works very very consistently
and gives you this rush. So then what
happens is
food will only release a fraction of
this. Right? So if you're doing cocaine,
you don't want food is irrelevant.
That's why you see a lot of crackheads
back in the crack epidemic days, they
were just skin and bone. They could care
less if it was food. You didn't give
them food, they wouldn't want it. Crack
is the only thing that would make them
happy. So so television, media, music
all mess with this system as well. God
designed the system so that you would do
things that are necessary for survival,
especially after sin. Eat, drink water,
and procreate so that the species
survives. Right? That is now not so much
there.
What you see instead is this. An
overwhelming Look, I mean you look at
this
Americans' use of electronic media is 11
plus hours a day. It's insane. So your
ministry, the ministry you guys have
here that addresses media is so critical
because from a a
quantity standpoint,
you are addressing one of the things
that has the highest quantity of
exposure to the enemy.
You get it? I mean literally if you if
you did one on school, it'd be less
hours than this. How else is the enemy
getting you his message? Like I mean
just think about the other things in
life. Like how are you learning about
him or his ways or whatever. The best
modeler that we have is just watch
somebody else. Let the mirror neurons in
your brain fire and if you're watching a
bunch of, you know, people going after
revenge or people cheating on their
spouse or whatever, you're now watching
that, you're going to repeat that. It's
the classic monkey see monkey do and
we're there. Yeah. And and this slide it
says over there too that it's a 2014.
Did I see Yeah, 2014.
This is worse today.
You know, you look at the smartphone
over there. It's like an hour and 25
minutes.
>> Today that's 6-7 hours. It probably
Yeah, it's probably doubled or tripled.
Cuz there's way more apps now that you
can go to. Yeah, this is this is
actually old. But I don't know that the
total number has changed, but definitely
what's in what place has definitely
changed. People don't watch live TV like
they used to.
You know, so it's dropped down. Radio is
was interesting. I've been talking to
Christian radio stations and radio is
still actually people still really do
listen to the radio if they're driving
around.
You know, there's still a lot of people
listen to radio. Satan does not
remove a resource. He just builds on it.
So he had first oral tradition, stories,
mythology, Greek mythology. You got
paper, those things got written down,
the Iliad, the Odyssey, the stuff like
that. You think, "Okay, paper, we don't
need paper anymore." Nope, he To paper
he adds first radio.
To radio he adds television. To
television he adds cable television. To
cable television he adds internet. To
internet he blah blah blah. So like you
don't get nothing's going away. You
still have oral tradition. I mean
there's still parts of the world where
oral tradition is. Satan doesn't lose a
weapon. He just builds more a bigger
arsenal around it. So you have to be
wise because the content is what
matters. What are we becoming when we
binge watch Babylon? When we literally
are watching what Babylon puts out. This
one is interesting. This this article is
an article that says, "Bring on the
nightmares. Why you should let your kids
watch horror movies."
Okay.
I don't think I agree with that. I mean
what would be your logical reason why?
Outline it. They outline this in the
article.
But let me say this. This is how Satan
wants to get your child. And you can see
the picture there is Poltergeist,
which is about demon possession. And
what they're trying to do is tell you,
"Listen, expose your child to demons."
That's what they're really telling you.
We did an episode or actually with David
Ong that we referred to in a different
recording that we did here just now. But
David Ong, he was very he his ministry
is basically about helping people get
out of demonic possession. And yet he
talks about horror movies and he's like,
"This is an entryway for the demons.
You're letting them in your life." I saw
that. We were we were doing Bible we
were doing door-to-door in San
Bernardino, California. I was a youth
pastor years ago. And some of my youth
went to a house and came back after the
first Sabbath that we went out and said,
"Dr. Walls, next Sabbath you got to come
to this house." They said, "You know,
the the young lady was crying. We prayed
with her. She says that when she goes to
when they go to sleep at night, when
they wake up in the morning, all the
furniture is automatically just
rearranged in the house and they don't
do it." Among other things. And I was
like, "You know what? Me to go back over
there? I don't really want to go." Next
Sabbath I go with them and we talk to
this young lady and it's it's really
deep. She says her brothers are in the
house sleeping with all these women,
smoking all these weed. Third thing,
watching all these horror movies.
And I said, "You have opened up They've
opened a portal into your house. Demons
have come in." And I joked and I said,
"And the demons don't like the way you
arrange your furniture."
>> [laughter]
>> Right. They've got a yeah, certain
pattern I'm sure that they want. You
know, we we hear this this from
interacting with young people all the
time and and when the topic of anime
comes up, we hear this actually quite
frequently about the demonic possession
and hearing hearing the demons begin to
speak to them. I've heard that over and
over from young kids and it's like I
don't think they realize like like how
could a cartoon or how could these fake
things do anything? And and I was
actually just talking one of the guys
that works with us. I worked with him in
television. And
he remembers going to this insane asylum
that we shot in the insane asylum. So
our production was going to there and a
horror movie was just getting off of
shooting. So as the two production
companies were switching, our production
company was coming in and setting up. We
were kind of like you know,
communicating with the other guys. And I
went straight over and I was like, "Hey,
I heard that there's always like
spiritualistic things that happen on
horror movies on the set when they make
them." And they said, "Absolutely,
100%." And and they said I and I asked
them, "What happened here at this one?"
And they said they'd see people walking
through walls, walking around the
hallways, and they were like not human.
And I mean that's just a normal thing,
common thing. [snorts]
Here we are. It's the end [music]
of the year. We have been so blessed by
your generosity, your prayers, and
[music] your comments. Every year we aim
to finish strong. And to do that, we
need your help. We have just hired a new
person because we want to make some
amazing videos, but there's a cost. In
this room we will soon have a video LED
wall. And we want to utilize that tool,
but there is a cost. We want to take
care of our employees, but there is a
cost. [music]
You know, Jesus came to this earth to
give us eternal life, but there was a
cost for that. We want others [music] to
experience eternal life as well. And so
we ask for your help. Please consider
making an end-of-year gift to one of
your favorite, if not your favorite,
ministry. And you can do that at
lls.tv/give. [music]
By texting little light at 53555.
Or by scanning the QR code on your
screen.
Ultimately, though, what the devil is
trying to do with us here is to
introduce people directly. So this show
that I'm sure you guys have done
something on the show Lucifer.
I found and I've never obviously I've
never seen the show. When I came out I
was like, "There's no way this is going
to be popular." Like people aren't crazy
enough to watch a show called Lucifer.
And not only was it popular, it was
super popular. It was seasons worth of
it. I don't know how many seasons.
>> among Christians. That's what scared me
the most.
>> You know his dad's a pastor? Get out.
That I did I did It's wild. That I did
not know. wild. Like can you imagine
honestly can you imagine your son oh by
the way my son's an actor and he plays
on this show called Lucifer like
Like people know what you do for a
living.
>> play on a show he is Lucifer on the
show.
>> Isn't that crazy? Here's I've been we
were in we were in
I won't say which country we're in we're
in Central or South America and I did a
talk on spiritualism and young people
and we talked about how Disney
really pushes spiritualism and a mother
came up to me after I said listen you
need to talk to my little girl she girl
was only like eight or nine she wants to
know why the magic she watches in Disney
is any different from the miracles that
Jesus does in the Bible and I'm like
well that tells you she's watching too
much Disney because you know
that's scary that she's already
comparing these two things as if they're
equivalent and and I said so you need to
stop watching this stuff have family
worship blah blah blah blah blah and the
mother says
uh yeah okay she said I said I said is
there anything else she said well I want
the mother says well I watch Lucifer
this TV show
>> Oh no.
>> You're a Christian why would you watch
it she said oh no no no no it's not bad
>> Yeah.
>> it's just entertainment No it's not just
she says it's just for the laughs. Oh
boy. Now let's go a little deeper into
the show I know you guys have done stuff
on it I believe that what they're trying
to do with this is rewrite the great
controversy.
Here Lucifer becomes the good guy Right.
Michael becomes the bad guy he's just
misunderstood.
>> He's just misunderstood this is goes
back to Rolling Stones Sympathy for the
Devil song this song as well as other
things are really pushing this narrative
so look at this so I this is how I found
out about shows I will not watch I find
a wiki page on it this is the episode
called Michael's wings from the show
Lucifer this is the description.
When Michael was battling Lucifer and
Amenadiel
in the Los Angeles Police Department he
unfurled his wings meaning he rolled out
his wings prior to his brother brothers
and prepared to battle
them at full strength.
Using the wings as weapons until God
arrived to halt the fighting. They then
reefurled their wings so Michael and
Lucifer are fighting God steps in the
scene now look at this next paragraph.
During the final battle with Lucifer to
decide who would be the next God that's
foolishness right there the brothers use
their wings to battle each other in the
sky after Michael was defeated
>> Oh wow. Lucifer used a flaming sword to
sever Michael's wings seeing it as
preferable outcome to the fight to the
death Michael had wanted.
>> That's exactly opposite of Revelation.
>> of Revelation Here's what's interesting
Lucifer is the one with the sword. Wow.
In the Bible Jesus is the one a sword
comes out of his mouth the sword of the
word of God.
>> Yeah. Here's the exact polar opposite
happening and so here's why this is
relevant we were doing Bible studies
with two high school kids
and this is the framework from which
we're now studying. Wow. So when you
start to teach them about who Jesus is
who Lucifer is there you have to
overcome the fact that they've now been
evangelized
into Luciferianism. Yeah yeah. That's
exactly what the show is designed for.
And not only not only that but it's
twisting it but you're also throwing off
what people believe Lucifer to be. Well
the Satan likes it when people doesn't
doesn't believe believes he doesn't
exist. Like so he uses that as a weapon
or as a way to deceive. Yep.
He's taking it to another level now he's
no longer trying to make people think he
doesn't exist
>> He's winning. he's trying to make them
think he's the good guy Mhm. and this
takes us to Marvel and everything else
but here's 2 Thessalonians 2 11 and 12
says this and for this cause God shall
send them strong delusion that they
should believe a lie that they all might
be damned who believe not the truth but
had pleasure in unrighteousness.
There is a delusion that's coming
Hollywood speaks about it unlimited
access to the world's influence there's
a great article here you guys may have
seen this from Living Waters Ministry
seven real examples that prove Hollywood
hates God I won't go through all of them
but I thought Susan Sarandon's words
were very interesting and most people
will recognize her face big Hollywood
star she says movies are important and
they're dangerous because we're the
keepers of the dreams Hollywood is the
keepers of the dreams you go into a
little dark room and become incredibly
vulnerable on the one hand all your
perspectives can be challenged you can
feel something you couldn't feel
normally they the movies can encourage
you to be the protagonist in your own
life here's her last line on the other
hand they can completely misshape you.
>> Wow. From the horse's mouth. This is not
a Christian Right.
>> This is Hollywood itself talking so they
in the article they give you these
examples there's seven of them I'll just
show two this is from a movie that I
thought was a good movie it's a true
story about a doctor named Patch Adams
I should say so it's a it's based on a
true story here's what he says and Robin
Williams of course everyone knows he's a
big star he says you created man man
suffers enormous amounts of pain man
dies maybe you should have had a few
more brainstorming sessions prior to
creation Wow. You just rested on the
seventh day maybe you should have spent
that day on compassion you know what
you're not worth it. Oh wow. So when you
watch Patch Adams I remember this is an
old movie very innocent I mean you know
you something you'd sit and let me
family would sit and watch
behind the scenes remember where your
brain is that's why I brought up the
science first
>> Yeah. your brain is in alpha wave mode
you are in a non critical thinking mode
you are semi hypnotized and then someone
says this passionately great actor nails
it you're watching it the music behind
it emotionally stirs you to sympathy and
guess what happens it waves over your
mind
>> that message.
>> and you take in the message the other
one that's interesting is this one
Hollywood versus Christianity in The
Simpsons one of the kids is asked to
thank God for a meal he says dear God we
paid for all this stuff ourselves so
thanks for nothing. You know it's hard
to even hear these words.
On this side it's hard to hear the
words.
Like you just kind of cringe inside and
just go uh man just
the arrogance of man to to not give
thanks that God is shining the sun on
both the the good and the wicked and you
know it's like the fact that you woke up
with a breath is only because of God
>> Mhm. and it's like they mocked this in
his face. You know talking about the
movie you mentioned with Robin Williams
I remember a few years ago when I was
I I start switching out
a long time ago like but movies I
consider bad like I'm not watching super
movies I'm not watching this I'm not
watching that
but I can watch a true story because I
thought yeah there's nothing wrong with
that like this guy this movie is based
on a true story and I was like this is
this is educational and there's
and some of those movies are literally
the story I couldn't find anything in it
that was improper in fact it was like
historical and taught me something about
history but then
I remember watching Hacksaw Ridge
and it was pretty gory I was like I'm
not really used to watching this kind of
goriness anymore but then once I started
work once I started working here
and I did a deep dive into for some kind
of an episode and Andrew Garfield who
played
Desmond Doss came up who played Desmond
Doss in Hacksaw Ridge he said oh yeah
you know when I had to play this role I
went to Desmond Doss's house and I
started touching his tools and I started
speaking to Desmond Doss and asking him
to help me play this role that's
spiritualism. There was a a particularly
profound moment where I went to um
Chattanooga Tennessee which is where
Desmond eventually retired and passed
away and I went on to his old property
[music]
um and went into his his old wood wood
wood shed and handled his tools and
walked around the lake that he would
walk around
and it was
I spent the day there just kind of
praying
>> [laughter]
>> and and and asking like
just guide me through this if you can I
mean tell me like tell me tell me what
to do tell me how to move tell me how to
speak tell me how to behave and I'll do
whatever you say so that that there was
some there there was [music] a
a strange mysterious spirituality
going on around the the making of this
film. And so he's playing a devout
Christian man it was a movie about this
man's faith but then he is dabbling with
spiritualism and a lot of actors do
that. Yeah. Very common Denzel
Washington talks about doing it. Yep. I
think Oprah maybe Yeah she does too mhm.
So [clears throat] it this is how they
do it though and again that's how they
nail the role so well sometimes I think.
Um but Hollywood you know I always say
it's it's you know it's the Druids
called um the holly plant
[clears throat] holy
and so that's what Merlin from Arthur's
court his magic wand was would have been
made out of Hollywood and Hollywood
California is still that magic wand
one of big franchises
and you guys have done a lot on it I've
done a lot on it you guys did stuff on
Black Panther and other stuff I've done
stuff on it because I was shocked when
churches rented out movie theaters to go
see Black Panther and I'm like he's
teaching the wrong state of the dead
they're doing voodoo like how do you do
that?
One of the things I found in my research
I thought was interesting was this so in
the Marvel multiverse
sagas the earth is numbered that they're
based out of is earth 616
and I was like what [clears throat] does
that mean so I looked it up
this is what Marvel says
Thorp states he came up with the number
through numerology 616 of which he has
was a student at the time subtracting
the number 50 from the number 666 a
number tied to Christian theology to
arrive at 616 as the home reality of the
Marvel universe Wow. So what does so we
all know what 666 would represent to him
what does the number 50 represent
>> Yeah I was just about to ask that. do as
thou wilt Oh seriously. do as thou wilt
that's how they came up with this with
that with the number for the main
universe. People think that this stuff
is just a story. How could this be
harmful? I mean, I hear this over and
over and over again. That's the That's
the one complaint. It's like, "Oh, you
guys are reading all this stuff into
it."
>> Really?
>> Not
But yeah, have you have Uh we didn't say
this. He said it.
>> Exactly. My simple question to everybody
that that has that mindset is like, have
you guys honestly deep dived into the
reasons why they do this? I mean, I
remember seeing um Good Fight Ministries
did a little something on the on the
Silver Surfer and uh they talked about
when that uh that character was being
created, I think it was um
Was it Jack Kirby? Jack Kirby was I
think it was Jack Kirby and he was
basically um
like they had pitched the story to him
and he was like, "No, no, I can't do
this. This is This is not right." or
whatever like that. Those guys that
wrote the story went to some church, got
some pastor to write some some letter or
something like this, and then they even
wrote it back saying like this was
teaching some godly things or whatever
like that. And that Jack Kirby said,
"Yes, you can do the story because this
pastor is what what says over this." And
it only came out later that that they
had totally made it up that the pastor
didn't write that letter and everything
like this. So, it was a total falsified
thing. Wow. And and and the the
Galactica, it was was a picture of God
and he's the evil villain. Mhm. And so,
it's like, you know, people go, "Oh,
this is just a story." Really? Like
really? These people go to great lengths
to have this like wild crazy junk into
this thing. It's not just a story. This
is spiritual warfare. That right there
is very spiritual. Yeah. I have one one
slide on a different talk that talks
about how Marvel basically and this it's
it's them talking. Every Marvel bad guy
is an is an iteration of Jehovah. Yeah.
Thanos is a type of Jehovah where he,
you know, he's going to make half the
universe disappear. That's like mocking
the flood and then the second coming.
Yeah. Galactus you Galactica so whatever
his name is, him.
Um all of them are a version of that.
Yeah. So, it's teaching kids to hate
God. There's one I do on the from one of
the Thor movies, Raguel, and there's
like this sun god that this guy finds.
Then he becomes the god butcher or
something. But in the dialogue and what
I do is I get cuz I don't watch them. I
just pull up the dialogue. He It
literally is as if he is this god is
telling you, "I don't really care about
you. There is no afterlife. There's
nothing to look forward to." If you're
watching this in a semi-hypnotic state,
you're getting this is how God sees of
me. Yeah. Right? You're This is So,
you're being reprogrammed. Now, let me
let me go back to something we said when
we did the episode on music.
As a young person, but even as an adult,
you may say, "You know, I just don't
feel like going to church anymore. I
don't feel like worshipping God anymore.
Uh it it's leaving me." You know why
it's leaving you?
>> Yeah. Because you've been programmed by
this. Mhm. There's a another set of
spirits at work that do not want to be
anywhere near the Holy Spirit. You think
it's your idea, young person, that you
don't want to go to church on Sabbath?
What your parents What's really happened
is you have allowed the demons to
reprogram you. Yep. And until you get
out from under that, you're not You're
going to just drift further and further
away from God. So, a couple more things.
This one I thought was interesting. No
wands or broomsticks. How television is
reinventing the modern witch. And so,
they've they've done a lot of work.
Charmed, first it was three white young
ladies. When they redid Charmed, they
put ladies of women of color.
Um and this is one of those This isn't
Charmed, but you know, they they 2024 is
set to be the year of the witch. Writers
are replacing the traditional image with
sassy, sexy, and dark characters. And
so, you see that. And then of course,
they brag, "Rapidly closing American
churches are shadowed
by the meteoric rise in witchcraft." And
so, we've talked about the fact that the
fastest growing religion among young
people in America is Wicca and
witchcraft. Churches are closing,
witchcraft is growing. Mhm. You got to
wonder when it's um you know, not to
pick on Disney constantly, but they have
all these witchcraft things and that's
children's material. And if you're a
child that's growing up on these stories
over the Bible stories, what do you
think you're going to graduate to when
you get older? You're going to gravitate
to the witchcraft. Of course. And and
the thing with witchcraft, it's it's it
it it leaves no restriction. In fact,
like Aleister Crowley, whose big line
was do as thou wilt shall be the whole
of the law, when one of the studies on
witchcraft I I put thing it it says,
"Witchcraft is non-conforming, blah blah
blah blah blah." And they say, "And you
can do as you want."
>> Oh, wow. I mean, that's part of the lure
in a world of vice is here's one that
you don't feel guilty. We're not going
to judge you. Now, in other talks I talk
about the fact that that doesn't work.
In fact, people still feel horrible
after they do all of these sinful
worldly things. It doesn't make them
feel better. It doesn't make them
complete people. Leaves them with more
anxiety, more depression, more feeling
of emptiness. But this the world wants
you to think if you follow your heart.
>> Mhm. And so, I talk about in in the
movie Coco, Ernesto de la Cruz I think
is the name of the chief character, he
says, "The world can follow the rules."
He says, "I will follow my heart." You
know what the Bible says about your
heart?
>> Yeah. It's deceitfully wicked. Yeah. Why
would you want to follow that?
>> True.
>> Frozen is all about that. Frozen is all
about Don't follow the rules and follow
your heart.
>> Yeah. One One article I saw
about Disney, the parent was saying, I
don't even think it was a Christian
parent saying she stopped letting her
kids watch Disney because it promotes
them disobeying their parents.
>> Yes. And then like almost every Disney
movie uh one of the themes is whoever
your authority figure is, don't follow
them. Don't listen to them. That's
right. Right? So,
I want to hit a couple other quick
things we're talking about TV. Um how it
corrupts children. There's research. Um
this article um research has long
established that teenagers who watch
movies or listen to music that
glamorizes drinking drugs drug use or
violence tend to engage in these
behaviors themselves. In 2012 a study
came out that movies influence teen
sexual attitudes and behaviors as well.
The study published in Psychological
Science found that the more teenagers
were exposed to sexual content in
movies, the earlier they started having
sex, and the likelier they were to have
casual unprotected sex.
By beholding, you become changed.
>> That's right. The science says it,
right? So, the big danger where we'll
we'll lead to is then pornography. Yes.
This is huge and I'm going to show you
some data here that shows you that you
are participating. The mirror neurons
are engaged. And you are really allowing
the devil to get you. So, this is again
secular research. Watching pornography
re-wires the brain to a more juvenile
state. A grown man watches pornography
and begins to reverse mature.
Interesting. Becomes more juvenile. Your
wife is not watching it.
>> Right. I'm just going to say this to
some man out there who's watching who
who watched pornography. She is not
becoming more childish, more juvenile.
You are. What do you think if before we
get into anything else pornography does,
what do you think that does to a
marriage? Uh it's going to tear you
apart. What does it do to the man who
isn't married and now is behaving more
like a boy, more childish because of his
viewing of pornography?
>> He's not going to get married.
>> Exactly. So, here's the studies. Porn
may literally shrink the brain. 2014
study [clears throat] from the Journal
of the American Medical Association
Psychiatry, men who regularly consume
pornography had smaller brain volume and
fewer connections in the striatum, a
brain region tied to reward processing
compared with those who didn't view
pornography. Uh the hypothalamus
also is activated the testicles, the
testes, to secrete testosterone. So,
sexually explicit material crafts a
brain that is constantly generating
testosterone and heighten sexual desire.
Instead of allowing boys to focus on
school, sports, music, sexually explicit
material causes a ramped-up sex drive
where their minds are inundated with
sexual thoughts.
>> And now kids are getting phones at 8, 9
years old and it's That's how they're
getting exposed to it. They they don't
even say anymore like if your kid is
exposed, they say when your kid is
exposed. And I've seen lots of times
parents are asking the question of like,
"When should we give a phone to our
children?" cuz they've been asking for
for many years. And they And the answer
is like when you want your kid to be
exposed to porn. Mhm. And what I say is
get them a Gabb phone. Mhm. Get them one
of the phones we talked about the
blocking device earlier. Yeah. Yeah,
that's like the phones. Gabb
will not allow for it. Uh so, I know
there's a some Adventist academies that
don't allow Blue Mountain Academy is one
of them that where you and I have both
been. It does not allow cell phones or
smartphones on campus. They do allow
these Gabb phones because you can't get
access to stuff on them. The kids hate
them. But that's one of the options. And
so, I would I just jump here. Early
exposure to porno- pornography is a form
of sexual trauma. I can see that. the
Journal of Psychiatry Reform. This is
not Christian material. Yeah. Right? So,
you don't want your child If you don't
want your child someone touching your
child, it's this it's it's almost an
equivalent to let them watch this stuff.
>> Don't set them up. A lot a lot of it is
actually just abuse young people in
pornography. Mhm.
Um
We find that this is from the article.
We find that pornography exposure is
widespread and normalized to the extent
that children cannot opt out. This is
what you were just saying. Wow. The
average age at which children see first
see pornography is 13. By age 9, 10% had
seen pornography. 27% had seen it by age
11. And half of children who had seen
pornography had seen it by the age of
13.
Why is this so relevant? The human
brain, the frontal lobe, isn't fully
developed till 25, 26 years of age. So,
this is clearly too early for this kind
of exposure. But you do not want the
child exposed to the stuff when they're
going through puberty.
It will literally change the way that
they're wired around sex and sexual
behavior forever. How is this impacting
the church? So, let's go here. The
majority of practicing Christians admit
to viewing pornography. Many uncom- Many
are comfortable with the habit. Here's
the data.
In general, 75% of Christian men and 40%
of Christian women reported consuming
porn on some level.
40% of women.
>> That's shocking. That's almost one in
two. I see more and more women when we
do these talks, more and more women come
up and say that they're also addicted.
Wow. And what goes along with this is
masturbation. Yeah. They almost say it's
like the same same between men and women
at this point, right?
>> This study This is This is of
Christians, though.
>> But but think of like why is that? It's
because of the things they're being fed
their whole lives. I I I think that
women, generally speaking, aren't as
Naturally speaking, aren't as easily
attracted to this. But
we did a show on Sabrina Carpenter.
You know, she is uh hugely expressive
expressively sexual in her videos, in
her music, in her shows, in her in her
concerts.
And so, but she does it from like almost
like a feminist point of view, like in
empowering and she's like, "I'm just
very comfortable with it and I just want
to tell people about it." So, for young
teenage Gen Z teenagers, Gen Z uh
millennial women who see that kind of
stuff, that's like their introduction to
it to the point where this is next,
right? Because, well, my idol Sabrina
Carpenter is talking about this and is
normalizing it, so I'm going to get
involved with this because clearly she's
having a good time, so we should be
watching this. Absolutely. And of
course, it's it's um
it's a way to damage. Remember Numbers
25? They were just about to go into the
promised land, the children of Israel.
We're doing That's in the Sabbath School
lesson now. Just about to go into the
promised land. How are they What
happens? Balaam and Balak conspire.
Later on in the Bible, you have to read
the whole Bible to get the whole story.
It's interesting. God doesn't tell you
what actually happens all right there in
the book of Numbers. But what happens is
they release the temple prostitutes on
the men,
get them to commit fornication. It
removes the protection off of God's
people and they then spend 40 years
wandering the wilderness when they could
have walked in after just a few weeks.
>> Crazy. That generation dies off. Except
for Joshua and Caleb, no one else goes
in. We are now on the borders of the
heavenly Canaan. Wow. Sexual sin will
again be how the devil gets people to
lose out on the promised land. I I
guarantee you this is a much larger
problem than what they even realize.
Let's look at Let's Let's look at this
worse. Despite the church's stance
against lust generally, it seems little
progress has been made to do better to
do to deter many of those who fill the
pews from pornography consumption. The
gap between professed belief and actual
behaviors raises questions about the
efficacy of current approaches within
faith communities. What may be more
troubling, here it is, is that well over
half of Christians who use pornography
say they are comfortable with their porn
use. Yeah. This is the real problem.
This is 2 Timothy
chapter
uh 3 verse 5, having a form of godliness
but denying the power thereof. What is
the power that they're denying? The
power of the Holy Spirit to make you
have a different appetite, to change
you. We need to Every men's ministry,
women's ministry needs to be
accountability agencies for for people.
Here it is. Matthew 5:27-28. Why is this
a sin? Jesus said so. You've heard it
was said of them by them of old time,
"Thou shalt not commit adultery." That's
the seventh commandment. Verse 28 says,
"But I say unto you that whosoever looks
on a woman to lust after her has
committed adultery with her already in
his heart." Then add in the mirror
neurons.
When you watch pornography, you are in a
perpetual state of sin. And what does
sin do? Separate you from God. That's
right. Why is the church in the
condition it's Why are so many people
leaving? Um you know, despite popular
belief, what really causes a lot of this
doubt is sin. It's secret sin. You're
holding on to sin, so you don't want
truth. You don't want doctrine. You
don't want the Holy Spirit around you.
Pornography is a secret way, just like
in Numbers 25, to separate you from God
so that you don't want anything to do
with him. And it works. And of course,
it damages the brain. Let me just show
you a couple of these slides. What porn
does to your brain and how to quit. We
talked about this already, but this is
your brain on heroin. This is your brain
on pornography to the right. Right? So,
it actually shrinks the brain. Why is
that relevant? It's shrinking the
frontoparietal regions, the frontal
lobe. Why is that relevant? Because
that's where the seal of God goes.
>> Yeah. If you don't If the less frontal
lobe you have, the less you will have to
work with in the work of salvation.
That's what the devil wants to damage.
And you can see here, healthy
volunteers, compulsive pornography
users.
>> Wow. And you can see that there is a
difference in the brain structure. It
literally changes you.
Um what And then we talked about how it
makes you a more more juvenile.
Um in the long term, pornography seems
to create sexual dysfunctions,
especially the inability to achieve
erection or orgasm with a real-life
partner. Marital quality and commitment
to one's romantic partner also appear to
be compromised.
So, there are young men who are fighting
back against this. I think we mentioned
this earlier.
There are young men now who have come
out and said, "Listen, I was bathed in
this stuff since I was 11, 12, 13, 14
years old. And now I cannot be happily
married. Nothing works in my romantic
life. We've got to shut this stuff
down." There are celebrities like um the
guy the black guy on um He always did
the like soap or no, the muscle guy or
something. I'm blanking on his name.
He's come out and talked about his
struggles with pornography. So has um
the British actor that was married to
Katie Perry. Um
Russell Oh, Russell Brand. Brand. He's
come out and talked about his struggles
with it. How it damages
their lives and their relationships. And
so, to sum it all up, listen. Revelation
3:10-11 says, "Because thou hast kept
the word of my patience, I also will
keep thee from the hour of temptation."
God can keep us from these things,
which shall come upon all the world to
try them that dwell upon the earth.
That's where we are, church.
Then Jesus says, "Behold, I come
quickly. Hold that fast which you have,
that no man take your crown." That's
right. Please, don't let them take your
crown. Don't let the porn industry, with
all of the trafficking it does, all of
the abuse of women, the objectifying of
women, do not let them take your crown.
Man of God, in your house, be priest and
king. Do not be a servant and slave to
Satan. Amen. Rule your house like God
has designed you to rule your sphere in
righteousness and holiness, not in this
kind of filth. You let this into your
house, you bring in demonic forces that
will corrupt not just you, but your
children. Right? So, don't even watch
it. A Bible verse I actually apply
uh as an equivalent. It's not
necessarily what the prophecy is
pointing towards, but I'll read it.
Revelation 12:14. "And to the woman,"
representing the church, "were given two
wings of a great eagle, that she might
fly into the wilderness into her place
where she is nourished for a time, and
times, and a half a time from the face
of the serpent." And we know that that's
the 1,260-year prophecy. Ends in 1798.
What happens after that? It says after
that, "And the serpent cast out of his
mouth water as a flood after the woman,
that he might cause her to be carried
away of the flood." So, now there's a
lot of ways we can interpret this flood,
and I'm not going to do the traditional
interpretation. I want to say that after
the church was put into a place of
protection, after 1798, something would
happen that would allow Satan to flood
the world with disinformation.
Something would happen. So, I do
presentations on end-time events. 1798
Daniel says in Hebrew in
in
chapter 12 of the of the book of Daniel,
he says that there's going to be
knowledge is going to increase at the
end of time. 1798 is the end of time.
And if you do a graph, you watch that
technology takes off right at the end of
the 1700s, just as predicted by Daniel.
And
now you have AI. I mean, we we are
beyond the reality of knowledge now to
the point where knowledge can make its
own knowledge. The AI can make its own
information and intelligence. So, we've
seen this, but this represents the fact
that something would happen where Satan
would be able to pour out a flood. And I
believe media, television,
um the music industry, now social media,
all ways the devil produces this flood.
And so, you know, he has a modern flood
is the way I say it. And you can look at
the numbers. Here's the hours of
American households
uh watched per TV per day. This is not
the latest data, but you can see
as you start in the mid uh of last
century, the 1949-1950,
you look at this astronomic increase
Wow. in the number of household
television hours watched per day.
That's a work day.
>> Yes. And poorer children
actually watch more TV than wealthier
children. And so, you can see that this
is a pretty serious effect. Then you see
this dip and you say, "Well, what
happened?" Well,
average daily media consumption per
person worldwide, TV is here.
Look at the internet. So, internet
streaming
replaced it, right? And so, now,
especially if you were someone who
worked in the entertainment industry,
estimated number of scripted original
television programs and series, you can
say that going up this is just to 2017.
It just
It just keeps going up up up and up
because there's more
channels, more streamers that need more
content. So, the content is actually
worse is what If you hear people talk
about the quality of what TV is
producing between reality TV and actual
content, people say, "It's just not as
good as it used to be." I don't think
people are as creative as they were back
in the '70s and '80s, like when Star
Wars was created, cuz they had to be
really creative. You don't have to be
really creative today. Right. It's
different. People are more addicted and
you have computer-generated images. You
can make things look really fancy. The
stories don't have to be as good.
>> Now, imagine this graph that you're
showing here is during a period where it
was a lot of effort to make a media
production. I mean, we're talking like,
you know, there's a reason why some of
the top Hollywood movies spend 400
million dollars making that movie. It's
a difficult thing to do. You have the
brightest minds on it. You have all the
like kind of latest and greatest
technologies to do those things. Now
your computer, what they're claiming it
will be possible to do in the next few
months is full-on CG like the best CG
movie Hollywood could ever produce by
you sitting there typing prompts. And
all And all you do is put in like the
script.
>> What's that going to do to the system?
You're talking about like this thing's
going up like this and the amount of
flood that's happening. Now you're
giving that power to every dog, cat, and
anybody else that can type something out
on the computer. Like this this world is
just going to get so many voices that,
you know, the ones that are out there
trying to push, you know, like, "Hey,
open your heart to Jesus." You know,
you're going to be a pebble in the
middle of an ocean. And that We've seen
that with YouTube.
You know, what amazes me with YouTube
when I go on is just how much content is
on there. Like there's no way that you
could ever watch it all. So let me go
back to the verse. The serpent is able
to flood. Yes. That's what's happening.
So it's So those of you out there who
have your own YouTube channels and
you're doing Christian things,
understand it really is I mean cuz I I
see some stuff and it's like 7 million
views and I'm like, "What? Yeah. Why
would this have 7 million views?" But
it's It has a lot to do with, I think,
there's some spiritualism to it. Like
what Does the devil Is the devil able to
draw people to?
But as you can see, these volumes are
up. I like what you just said. I didn't
know that. The volumes are going to
continue to go up of what's produced.
And in in in in conclusion, our last
verse,
uh we're talking about We've been
talking about television. Here's what I
say. Finally, brethren Well, I don't say
it. Philippians Paul says it in
Philippians 4:8. Paul says, "Finally,
brethren, whatsoever things are true,
whatsoever things are honest, whatsoever
things are just, whatsoever things are
pure, whatsoever things are lovely,
whatsoever things are of a good report,
if there be any virtue, and if there be
any praise,
think on these things."
>> Amen. Amen. Amen.
>> Men, especially, be priests in your
home. Mhm. That means that you can't
have the altar of the television and the
altar of God in the same place. That's
how the children of the the the kings of
Israel did it. And they failed. There
was never a righteous king in all at all
ever in the northern kingdom of Israel.
Not one righteous king. It just went
down down down.
>> went down. Right. Remove that altar. And
I'm not saying there's never going to be
anything to watch of value. Obviously,
there's some
good Christian programming you can
watch. But you've got to make sure that
the word of God, the study in the home,
family worship, time with your wife, if
you're a young person, time in the word,
time outside is more important than
this. Yep.
So. I agree. I believe it.
>> Wow. Amazing. Thank you, Dr. Walsh, for
coming by and blessing us. If you guys
want to check out more stuff from him,
we'll put a link in the description
where you can hear some of his sermons,
but
keep fighting the good fight.
Keep spreading the news, and thank you
for coming by and blessing our channel.
>> Thank you for having me, and you guys
keep doing what you do. You guys are a
major blessing. Praise God. We've been
watching you guys for years at our
house. We love when you break things
down. It is just always so well done.
And let me say this, and audience, I
want you to kind of come into this as
well. We need to be praying for these
ministries. Amen. Because the devil does
not want your ministry to be successful.
He wants to try and attack it. He will
attack it because we are attacking his
kingdom. He's going to come back. But
like the old Testament prophet says,
"When the enemy comes in like a flood,
Yep. the spirit of the Lord will lift up
a standard against him. We stand with
God, and we know the His spirit will
protect us." I know.
>> [music]